our philosophy is we want to be
considered like a best-in-class business
yeah and that sounds like an obvious
thing but a lot of companies aren't
geared up to be that they want to be
every man every person kind of thing
like we want to be like a premium brand
that offers a really high level of
service to our candidate and clients our
philosophy at the start is like hey this
is a platform people that want to be
successful that want to be good our
philosophy has been let's invest in
people as much as we can let's give them
an l d wrap let's put them in some teams
whether they can be effective let's give
them good Market strategy then let's
really encourage them let's treat them
like grown-ups like we're not hovering
over you as a result of us not hovering
over you there's an expectation around
your performance and you know you're
ultimately responsible for that